in the Tenderloin hates to be hilarious
and burst each other's chops and stunts
and punishments the titular Impractical
Jokers can get well carried away the
kooky antics of q Murr Joe and Sal can
and do veer into the unseemly dangerous
or even illegal as these extreme
examples demonstrate a very special 2014
episode featured may be the most extreme
punishment yet and one that would be
hard to top as it involved parties
outside of the practical jokers foursome
as well as the government and most
likely a great deal of paperwork Jenna
volcano is a recurring Impractical
Jokers cast member showing up whenever
her brother Sauer needs to be made
especially uncomfortable by his cronies
her appearances usually involve staging
some kind of intimate encounter with the
three Jokers a ton Sal the third season
finale brother and last tops them all
Sal lost the episode and for his
punishment he had to watch alongside his
family and friends as Murr married Jenna
that's really going above and beyond and
the duo really did tie the knot however
briefly in fact following his
matrimonial episode Murr even tweeted
yes I legally married Sal's sister no
joke and yes we are know the marriage
after the honeymoon night dental
procedures are among life's most and
pleasant and potentially painful things
so even the idea of delving into that
world as part of an otherwise innocuous
and silly prank show feels a bit beyond
the payoff and yet on a 2014 episode of
Impractical Jokers
that tenderloins made Murr a man
purported to be their friend submit to
some unnecessary and deeply
uncomfortable oral treatment for his
punishment having lost the episode
because the dental aesthetic of
novocaine is a powerful numbing agent
it's inherently funny to listen to
somebody try to use the mouth they
cannot feel not to mention try to eat
food Murr thus enjoyed some novocaine
shots and then had to talk about a
variety of foods while also eating them
braised beef braised beef is brilliant
braised meat braised beef
in short he made a terrible mess the
bits had long lasting implications for
Murr to responding to an Impractical
Jokers fan on Twitter Moe revealed that
since the know became related punishment
he's now quote more sensitive to it
complicating future dental surgeries now
that's suffering for one's art
the permanent punishments the title of a
2014 Impractical Jokers episode is also
unfortunately for three Jokers a spoiler
in a prank involving attach balloons on
to people just trying to grocery shop
Cube Murr and Sal in other words
everyone except Joe fails and gets their
punishment for each guy it's a possibly
eternal reminder of that time they
didn't succeed on their silly reality
show a tattoo The Joker's go under the
need of the link to receive the worst
and dumbest tattoos this side of jackass
Q's consists of a cat along with a
caption 38 lives alone has three cats
that's smugly embarrassing but not as
ridiculous and pointless as Murr sweet
body art depicting a ferret skydiving
again that's funny and humiliating
former but the hardest weirdest and
silliest permanent ink of all went on to
poor Sal
because rules are rules and punishments
must be accepted on Impractical Jokers
he gots a fighter too a musician actor
and celebrity offspring Jaden Smith and
let's be honest it's not even a
particularly lifelike likeness of the
rising star either the Impractical
Jokers loses his 2015 episode is once
again Sal and his co-stars like the
deceptively simple both no less
humiliating punishment the group heads
to a New Jersey escape room called exist
strategy and makes Sal go through the
experience get locked in a room and sold
riddles to get out with a group of
strangers but going through too small
the entertaining crew pelting is not the
entirety of the punishment Sal has to
pee his pants were locked in a small
enclosed space with other people
urinating on oneself falls well outside
the box of what's considered normal and
acceptable adult behavior but Sal is
faced with having to fake a bathroom
emergency then make their problem
well rectify itself he literally starts
to sweat and the others try to force his
hand or bladder by playing running water
sounds through his earpiece
finally Sal does what he has to do and
you're an ace in full view of everyone
in the escape room fully staining his
lightly colored khakis it's so freaks
out ISM witting escape room companions
at some scream and some can't help but
laugh but he still can't get out of the
room into the solution can be found
forcing pee-soaked Sal to work in close
contact with these strangers that was
awesome
Moe and Joe lost the 2014 Impractical
Jokers episode leaving them to a
punishment called strip high-five both
would stand the New York City's Union
Square and ask pedestrians for
high-fives
every time they refused the Joker's must
remove an article of clothing and the
punishment is over and one of them winds
up completely naked and on screen
graphic reveals that sullen Kew almost
replaced the punishment because they
thought getting high-fives would be too
easy for Moe and Joe and thus nobody
would get nude at first it looks like
that instinct was correct as the to
easily get strangers to slap their palms
then the goodwill of their fellow humans
dry up and both Murr and Joe a foster
removed more and more with Joe losing
both his shirts and pants before his
opponent adding insult to injury
murrs discarded sweat shirt gets swiped
by a rude stranger
the battle goes down to the wire with
both guys left in their underwear and
Murr ultimately losing it takes him a
good three minutes to steel himself for
the demeaning and illegal act of
exposing himself in front of the Gabbard
crowd and that's when New York City
police arrive and put an end to the
shoot they didn't arrest anybody but
they most certainly could have as
exposing one's private parts on the
streets is quite illegal check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos but your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you